bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant l'audition de jean-louis
nadal devant la commission des lois du
sénat l'ancien magistrat a été confirmée
hier au poste de président de la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique son nom avait été proposé par
françois hollande puis confirmez donc
hier par les deux assemblées jean louis
nadal qui dit ne pas vouloir faire de ce
poste un rôle d'inquisiteur on se
retrouve tout de suite après mes chers
mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs
la séance est ouverte
je vous demander de bien vouloir
rejoindre vos places mes chers collègues
je précise à mes collègues de la
commission des lois que nous avons
interrompu l'examen du texte sur eux les
gens du voyage ainsi que le texte de
monsieur del picchia qui seront à
nouveau à l'ordre du jour demain à 9h30
suite à la décision de la commission
pour faire le travail correctement
je vous prie de bien vouloir vous
installez et je vous indique que nous
entendons aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
la procédure prévue par l'article 13 de
la constitution
monsieur jean louis nadal dont la
candidature a été présentée par monsieur
le président de la république pour être
nommé président de la haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
dont le parlement a décidé la création
je vous rappelle que la haute autorité
est une autorité administrative
indépendante créée par la loi du 11
octobre 2013 pour reprendre les missions
de la commission pour la transparence
financière de la vie politique
conformément à la loi organique et à la
loi du 23 juillet 2010
le président de cette haute autorité ne
peut être nommé que si la majorité des
trois cinquièmes des suffrages exprimés
des commissions des lois de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat n'ont pas émis
d'avis contraire
le vote aura donc lieu à la suite de
cette audition et le dépouillement sera
simultanée entre nos deux commissions
des lois
l'audition est publique ouverte à la
presse est donc ouverte à toutes les
personnes qui souhaitent venir les
délégations de voc ne sont pas autorisés
alors eux comme nous avons dû nous
mettre d'accord avec l'assemblée
nationale pour que le vote ait lieu en
même temps
nous allons si vous le voulez bien le
procédé au vote à 12 heures 30 dans la
salle de la commission
je vais donner la parole à monsieur jean
louis nadal
que nous sommes bien sûr heureux
d'accueillir car nous connaissons bien
son parcours vous savez monsieur nadal
vous étiez jusqu'en février 2011
procureur général près la cour de
cassation
depuis votre accès en 1970 à la
magistrature vous avez exercé des
responsabilités éminentes au sein du
parquet étant notamment procureur
général auprès de 3 cour d'appel bastia
lyon et aix-en-provence
avant de diriger à compter de 2004 le
parquet général près la cour de
cassation
vous avez rendu le 28 novembre un
rapport remarqué à madame la garde des
sceaux pour refonder le ministère public
et comme vous avez bien voulu
m'auditionner pendant une heure et demie
vous voyez qu'il y a comme ça dans la
vie des retour des choses nous sommes
très heureux aujourd'hui de vous poser
quelques questions alors mes chers
collègues pour respecter le talent le
temps ce qui était demandé par plusieurs
d'entre vous de surcroît monsieur le
procureur général va faire son exposé
liminaire
ensuite je vous propose de prendre
toutes les questions de manière à ce que
en un exposé au final une réponse
globale
monsieur le procureur général puisse
répond puisse répondre à chacune et
chacun d'entre vous êtes vous d'accord
sur cette procédure tout le monde est
d'accord donc je donne immédiatement la
parole à monsieur jean louis nadal
presse qu'il faut voilà merci monsieur
le président en sueur merci
l'exigence de transparence et de
moralisation de la vie publique n'est
pas nouvelle
la mémoire des parlementaires
expérimentés de votre commission doit
rejoindre les souvenirs de l'ancien
magistrat qui est devant vous
aujourd'hui
chacun peut se souvenir que toutes les
affaires politico financières ont toutes
été conduites ont toutes conduit à des
améliorations des lois et des
dispositifs législatifs comme
réglementaire on peut le déplorer mais
l'histoire est clair
les affaires liées au financement des
partis politiques des campagnes
électorales au cours des années 80 ont
conduit à l'adoption d'une première loi
en 1988 sous le gouvernement de jacques
chirac avant qu'une nouvelle loi soit
votée en 1990 sous le gouvernement de
michel rocard qui faisait des questions
de transparence de vérité et de
réconciliation de l'état et de la
société civile de la confiance et de
l'intelligence de nos concitoyens la kz2
sa politique
quelques décennies plus tard quand vous
le dites vous-même notamment dans votre
excellent rapport monsieur le président
en sueur c'est loi relative à la
transparence avis public marque une
étape décisive dans l'amélioration du
dispositif français de prévention et de
répression des atteintes à la probité
publique
cette étape ce n'est pas pour une fois
une inflation pénales non maîtrisée mais
des notions une institution nouvelle
centré sur la prévention la pédagogie
sur la déontologie
ce mode déontologie est un bon mot
d'ailleurs que paul ricoeur travail à
mieux que personne pour lui ce n'est pas
les tic qui épure interrogations ni la
morale qui est définition selon rigueur
la déontologie et pratique elle est
fonctionnelle et professionnels il me
semble donc que l'on doit pas prendre
ces notions nouvelles je pense à la
définition par exemple du conflit
d'intérêt de façon trop rigide car elle
doit systématiquement elle doit être
systématiquement pensé comme une aide à
la bonne décision comme un appui
fonctionnel dans le cas de l'exercice
d'une fonction ou d'une profession
je sais à cet égard que votre commission
s'est attaché à concilier plusieurs
exigences des gars l'importance que ce
soit la publicité des informations
déclarées et le droit à la vie privée le
contrôle par un organe extérieur et la
séparation des pouvoirs ou
l'indépendance de l'élu et la liberté de
mener une activité de son choix
j'ai compris aussi que votre travail a
été guidé dans sa réflexion par les
travaux précédemment menées par un
groupe de travail pluraliste
institué en novembre 2010 sous la
présidence du sénateur jean jacques
hyest qui ont donné lieu en mai 2011 un
rapport d'information comprenant 40
recommandations relatives à la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts pour
les bandes pour les parlementaires
s'appuyant sur des comparaisons
internationales certaines furent prises
mais pas toutes
chacun se souvient aussi également que
c'est au sénat à la quasi unanimité
que vous avez adopté le dépôt par le
gouvernement d'un document budgétaire
retraçant l'utilisation fait de la
réserve parlementaire j'ai donc
parfaitement conscience que vous serez
exigeant avec l'application de ces deux
lois qui portent plus que tout autre
l'empreinte d'un travail parlementaire
de façon générale je sois dire
s'agissant du contexte qui entoure
l'entrée en vigueur de ces textes que
beaucoup d'entre vous
d'entre nous s'insurge contre les
sondages qui révèle une défiance
grandissante inquiétante des français à
l'égard de leurs représentants
j'ai la conviction que la faute
quelques-uns ne peut emporter l'opprobre
contre tous les autres qui hier ce qui
exercent leur mandat dans le respect des
principes qui fondent leur engagement
cette interrogation
dans le pays rejoint toutefois
l'actualité la plus récente comme la
publication des dernières évaluations
internationales du conseil de l'europe
de l'oscd et de transparancy
international
elle montre l'urgence de rendre plus
effectives les mesures destinées à
combattre certaines pratiques qui minent
la confiance entre le citoyen et les
institutions de la république c'était
déjà le sens des recommandations de la
commission pour la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts dans la vie publique
confiant 2010 au vice président du
conseil d'état jean marc sauvé à c les
gars après la décision du conseil
constitutionnel
il m'apparaît que votre vision
équilibrée et pondéré l'a emporté les
conclusions de la commission sauvé comme
les dispositions législatives adoptées
le 17 septembre dernier rejoigne les
leçon que je tire de mon expérience de
40 années au sein de la magistrature les
atteintes à la probité publique
apparaissent et prospère essentiellement
lorsque la transparence des flux
financiers est insuffisante et lorsque
les frontières entre le licite et
l'illicite sont brouillées ou ignorés
par ceux là même qui sont en charge de
veiller à l'état de droit
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
je comprends que l'ambition du
législateur par le vote de cette loi et
la création de cette autorité est
d'abord de rétablir en tout cas de s'en
donner les moyens la confiance entre les
citoyens et les détenteurs d'un mandat
électif d'une mission ou d'une fonction
dans la vie publique après laffaire
cahuzac mais surtout de créer un garant
de cette confiance car la confiance ne
se donne que si elle se mérite
or or aujourd'hui les citoyens éprouvent
le besoin d'obtenir en plus de leur
jugement personnel une garantie
objective venant une institution de la
république
établissant que les responsables chargés
des affaires la cité sont dignes de
confiance et que les citoyens peuvent
avoir foi en eux et j'utilise mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs à dessein ce mot
deux fois car c'est une portée sacré
qu'il avait dans la vie publique à rome
rome qui nous a transmis cette
magnifique expression de la finesse
république à la fois publique la forme
la plus haute de la confiance que doit
inspirer un magistrat en charge des
affaires la cité et dont il doit
témoigner par la noblesse de son
comportement fait de loyauté et de
dignité
c'est tout c'est tout le sens
de l'article 1er de la loi qui propose
ces mots magnifiques dignité probité
intégrité mot magnifique dont le texte
pourrait être non seulement celui d'une
obligation légale mais aussi celui d'un
serment tel que la république le demande
déjà beaucoup de ses serviteurs
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs quand
vous le savez ces lois visent à donner
corps à ces valeurs républicaines
en suivant trois chemins celui de
nouvelles déclarations d'intérêts et de
patrimoine pour favoriser la
transparence démocratique
je le dis haut et fort je serai attentif
d'une attention sans faille à ce que
l'intrusion dans la vie privée soit la
plus limitées et conformes aux objectifs
de la loi dans le prolongement de la
décision du conseil constitutionnel qui
a fixé des bornes précis sur la question
des proches ou ou de la publication en
son temps la commission de réflexion sur
la prévention des conflits d'intérêts
dans la vie publique
résumé ainsi l'enjeu de la réforme elle
doit reposer sur un équilibre un
équilibre pertinents et le cas échéant
évolutif entre transparence et
protection de la vie privée confiance et
responsabilité prévention renforcée
centurions adapté cette balance des
droits cette balance des droits quand la
protection des libertés individuelles
sont des impératifs quotidien pour les
magistrats judiciaires
le deuxième chemin c'est celui de
nouveaux contrôles autour d'une autorité
administrative
doté de véritables pouvoirs nous devrons
mobiliser je dis bien nous devrons
mobiliser les services notamment des
ministères de la justice de l'intérieur
du budget pour épauler la création de la
haute autorité ce sera l'un des défis
des premiers mois ce défi ne sera pas
mince et je trouverais à cet égard
particulièrement utile que le suivi de
l'application de ces lois soient
particulièrement étroit par le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale
troisième chemin c'est celui de
dispositifs contraignants moderniser je
pense à la peine d'inégibilité renforcer
vos incompatibilité nouvelle pour les
membres du gouvernement dans la mesure
où ces dispositions relèvent de la
justice
et où des bureaux des assemblées elles
sont hors champ de la haute autorité je
souhaite consacrer l'essentiel de mon
bref propos au développement de cette
autorité administrative indépendante que
vous avez créés mais là mais chez les
sénateurs l'idée fondatrice de la loi
nouvelle et qui est le socle des
missions confiées à la haute autorité eh
bien d'abord de responsabiliser les
acteurs publics en leur demandant de
procéder à des déclarations
patrimoniales et d'intérêts dont le
suivi doit assurer le niveau de
transparence nécessaire pour permettre
une prévention effective et efficace
toute mon expérience de magistrats
convergent vers le constat qu'il n'est
de bonnes décisions qu accepter et pour
qu'elle le soit il faut qu'elles soient
lisibles ce qui implique de la part de
ceux qui la rendent un effort d'écouté
est explications forte de l'exemple du
fonctionnement de l'ancienne commission
pour la transparence financière de la
vie publique la haute autorité disposera
désormais de pouvoirs de vérification
d'injonction et de transmission aux
autorités fiscales ou judiciaires la
haute autorité contribuera à mieux
garantir la probité publique en
s'assurant que la confiance que les
citoyens doivent à leurs institutions
politiques soient confortés ou restaurés
par des actions précises mener je le dis
bien
contradictoirement impartialement est
effectivement
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs assumer
la présidence de la haute autorité
serait pour moi l'occasion d'agir dans
la continuité de mon engagement fidèle
et constant à l'état au service de
l'état à l'état de droit de la loi du
culte de la loi et de la démocratie
cette continuité je m'aperçois sur
plusieurs plans premièrement c'est le
respect le plus absolu de l'état de
droit dans sa conception la plus élevée
qui impose de veiller à ce que les lois
de la république soit exactement
appliquée née dans une recherche
constante du meilleur équilibre entre le
principe d'égalité de tous devant la loi
et le principe
adaptation de celle ci aux spécificités
des 10 des situations et des personnes
deuxièmement c'est l'exigence de lutte
contre les atteintes à la probité
publique qui est précisément la vocation
de la haute autorité mais qui fut
également l'une des exigences les plus
constantes de ma vie de magistrats et
pour y porter remède la répression
quelquefois nécessaire mais la pédagogie
ne l'est pas moins je le répète la
pédagogie est essentiel me paraît en
effet essentiel aux fins de la
prévention une pédagogie constante de
l'application de la loi qu'elle soit
pénale administrative et financière le
rôle du conseil est essentielle
troisièmement c'est la complémentarité
la complémentarité du rôle de la haute
autorité et du rôle des institutions qui
lui sont proches et le nécessaire
dialogue qui doit résulter je trouve
dans les textes qui définissent le rhône
la haute autorité le rappel de cette
exigence de dialogue et de partenariats
avec différentes institutions de l'état
cette logique de contact confiant avec
d'autres institutions publiques
respectueux des pouvoirs respectifs de
chacune elle a toujours été ma ligne de
conduite à la tête des parquets généraux
exposé de bastia lyon aix en provence ou
parquet général de paris et comme
procureur général la cour de cassation
j'ai pu mesurer notamment dans mes
fonctions de ministère public près la
cour de justice de la république toute
l'efficacité des échanges nourris avec
la cour des comptes comme avec les
membres du parlement
4 et n en sais je crois au mérite du
fonctionnement collégial
l'organisation même de la haute autorité
que ce soit les relations
qu'entretiendront ses membres le
dialogue et les rapporteurs le
secrétariat général sera nécessairement
un travail d'équipé où chacun a vocation
à exercer pleinement les responsabilités
qui sont propres mais dans un but commun
cinquièmement c'est le caractère
exemplaire du point de vue des valeurs
démocratiques du fonctionnement de la
haute autorité
la déontologie de la haute autorité et
de tous ses membres est un principe non
moins essentielle dont j'ai pu mesurer
l'importance dans l'exercice de mes
responsabilités adecco nationale la
magistrature ou au conseil supérieur de
magistrature tout autant que dans
l'exercice de mes responsabilités
exercées au titre et specter générale
des services judiciaires
je voudrais enfin corps mon propos en
réfléchissant tous avec vous aux actions
aux actions à conduire pour magnifier
l'importance l'impact que la haute
autorité doit avoir sur la vie publique
de notre pays d'un point de vue général
je suis sensible à cette observation
faite au cours des débats parlementaires
comme dans l'avis rendu en juin dernier
par l'assemblée plénière de la
commission consultative des droits de
l'homme de la nécessité de faire en
temps utile c'est-à-dire sans
précipitation mais quand même aussi
rapidement que possible un bilan des
travaux conduits par l'ensemble des
dispositifs publics précise par la
matière votre commission s'est interrogé
à ce sujet et avait sollicité un rapport
au gouvernement sur ce sujet
la haute autorité se tiendra au service
des membres du parlement qui voudront se
saisir de ces questions qui engagent non
seulement des moyens budgétaires il ya
je crois un rapport budgétaire de
monsieur gore sur la question mais aussi
de l'efficacité de l'ensemble du
dispositif préventif dans ses
perspectives trois axes d'action
pourrait mobiliser plus particulièrement
l'attention de la haute autorité
enfin en matière de prévention d'abord
la haute autorité pour assumer un rôle
d'information et de formation auprès des
institutions qui contribuent à la
formation des cadres de l'état
dans ce contexte des partenariats
pédagogiques pour être envisagée avec
les grandes écoles de service public
lena adn m le centre national de
formation professionnelle de la fonction
publique territoriale etc acceptera en
matière de rayonnement international
ensuite la haute autorité devrait
veiller à entretenir un dialogue
constant avec les institutions
européennes et internationales
compétentes en matière de probité
publique
les lois que vous avez voté mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs place la france
en tête des grandes démocraties
mon expérience d'initiateur du réseau
européen des procureurs généraux
des cours suprêmes européenne que j'ai
présidé me permet d'estimer que la
participation active la haute autorité
au grand réseau de lutte contre ces
phénomènes devraient être privilégiés
l'influencent du droit européen
notamment en matière de droit de la
commande publique et des recommandations
issues des organisations internationales
sont déjà manifeste pour mémoire en 2003
l'organisation de coopération de
développement économiques ocde a ainsi
approuvé des lignes directrices pour la
gestion des conflits d'intérêts dans le
service public parallèlement le conseil
d'europe le conseil l'europe a créé en
mai 90 la commission européenne pour la
démocratie par le droit plus communément
appelée commission de venise qu'a rendu
déjà plusieurs avis sur le sujet
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
l'institution d'un comité d'éthique a
été copiée de par le monde il peut en
être de même avec la haute autorité en
matière enfin d'établissement d'une
véritable doctrine public et
contradictoire il conviendra de préciser
et aux décors aux nouveaux outils et aux
nouvelles normes que vous avez adopté ce
sera l'occasion d'affiner les contours
de la notion de conflit d'intérêts de
construire un corpus déontologique
véritable cadre de référence pour
l'ensemble des statuts et domaines
d'activités concernés dans une société
démocratique avancée c'est cette marche
grise de non droit des conflits
d'intérêts qu'il faut faire régresser
afin qu'au lieu d'être ignoré certaines
situations soient organisées par le
droit je sais à cet égard que votre
commission aurait souhaité préciser la
définition du conflit d'intérêts en
excluant l'hypothèse d'un conflit entre
intérêts publics et en écartant la
théorie des apparences que le conseil a
finalement validé je crois tout de même
je crois tout de même qu'il faudra ainsi
que vous l'aviez exprimé objective et
une définition qui pourrait être trop
marquée par un risque de subjectivité
ce serait l'occasion de préciser ce
système de déport imposant par exemple
aux membres des autorités
administratives indépendantes se
trouvant dans une situation de conflit
d'intérêts l'obligation de s'abstenir de
prendre part à la sphère où la décision
est en cause il s'agit d'une traduction
moderne de la maxime de droit latin
selon laquelle on ne peut être juge et
partie sa mise en oeuvre va sans doute
resserré quelques difficultés
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je veux
être terre je n'ose dire transparent
la transparence est un moyen la
transparence est un moyen et non une fin
en soi le système panoptique de bentham
dans laquelle la surveillance de tous
est assurée par un contrôle permanent de
chacun ne peut être le modèle n'a peu de
prouver que modèle pour envisager le
rôle et les missions de la haute
autorité quand vous le rappeler récit
pitt votre apport monsieur le président
en sueur selon l'article 15 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme la
société a le droit de demander compte à
tout agent public de son administration
ces mots traduit une exigence
démocratique
un impératif républicain qui court à
travers les siècles et qu'il nous
appartient ensemble de garantir cette
exigence cette exigence de rendre des
comptes devrait également être au coeur
de l'action de la haute autorité comme
de son président c'est en tout cas ainsi
que j'envisage l'exercice de cette
responsabilité
je vous remercie
merci à monsieur le procureur général
d'avoir bien voulu nous faire part avec
force de vos convictions
je crois que chacun et chacune a été
très attentif à vos propos je me
permettrai une question il ne vous a pas
échappé que le texte adopté par
l'assemblée nationale
est différent de celui qui avait été
adoptée en nouvelles et dernière lecture
par le sénat
le sénat avait voté la publication
intégrale du patrimoine des députés et
des sénateurs au journal officiel
l'assemblée nationale a adopté un
système selon lequel tous les citoyens
c'est à dire tous les électeurs 40 ou 45
millions de personnes pourrait aller
consulter ces patrimoines dans les
préfectures mais que la publication de
ce qui est désormais ce qui sera
universellement consultables sera
sanctionnée de 40000 euros damende je
voulais vous demander si vous pensez que
ce dispositif
aura une quelconque efficacité comment
empêcher la publication de ce qui est
consultable par 40 millions de personnes
c'est une question je me pose depuis
l'adoption de ce texte et je me permets
de la pause et j'avais d'autres
questions mais je en particulier la
question de savoir si à côté des
fonctions de contrôle et d'injonctions
qui sont celles de la haute autorité
celle ci pourrait conseiller ou éclairer
les personnes qui s'adressent reda el
mes chers collègues y at il des demandes
de parole pour poser des questions à
monsieur le procureur général alors je
prends les inscrits à monsieur y est
il n'y a pas d'autres orateurs ça
m'étonne cela madame qu kerman
monsieur
monsieur michel pense que c'est très
clair et très complet très bien il n'y a
pas d'autres intervenants peut-être
viendront-ils tout à l'heure monsieur y
est vous avez la parole
oui merci monsieur le président
ce qui nous avait rappelé tous les
travaux faits par le sénat c'est le
procureur général et effectivement on
avait été quand même assez loin je ne
partage pas forcément les idées de jean
pierre sueur en ce qui concerne la
publication
intégrale parce que je pense que ça
vient ça tourne vite à la
ces pour les médias a pu alors voilà on
compare les patrimoines enfin des choses
qui sont assez
c'est pas c'est pas l'intérêt monsieur
revol c'est toute la question des
conflits d'intérêts le procureur général
parce que
les patrimoines on verra bien s'ils ont
évolué et c'était déjà le cas
aujourd'hui
sauf que il n'y avait pas les moyens de
vérification ce que vous aurez vous
l'avez 10 avec des services notamment
le ministère de l'économie et des
fiancés il faut être clair
et donc cette prime de la déontologie et
moi quand j'ai toujours dit que c'était
moi les parlementaires qui était en
cause
sur les conflits d'intérêts que
l'immense armée des élus locaux dont
vous allez avoir la responsabilité
ce que les présidents de conseils
généraux les vice présidents ayant
délégation etc ils vont tous entrer et
c'est pas c'est pas les 900
parlementaires c'est que vous allez
jouer de ses bons coups et ça représente
4000 à peu près oui
8009 nord on voit leur voix l'immensité
de la tâche et et on le sait bien et
comme vous avez été
procureur procureur général etc vous
avez bien vu que c'était la commande
publique etc qui posait souvent des
problèmes mais tout est affaire
qui agite à juste titre mais qui sont
des affaires judiciaires désormais ça
vient de là donc c'est toute la question
comment vous allez pouvoir il va bien
falloir que vous fassiez je devrais pas
un arbitrage mais vous n'avez pas
pouvoir traiter tous de la même manière
et alors ma question complémentaire
on a beaucoup mis dans la loi qu'il y
avait les alertes danseurs d' alerte les
les
les associations qui se préoccupe de la
transparence n'est ce pas et donc quel
sera leur lit le rapport que vous les
rapports que vous aurez avec tous ces
bons donneurs de leçons qui sont
meilleurs que tout le monde d'ailleurs
en général et qu'ils veulent qu'ils
veulent en permanence
que la transparence soit tellement
parfaite que que n'existera plus courts
fête alors merci monsieur yes si
monsieur yes mö le père mais j'ajoute
une question complémentaire puisque vous
nous dites qu'il y à 6900
assujettis compte tenu des moyens qui
seront les vôtres envisagez-vous de
d'étudier et de contrôler chacune des
huit mille neuf cent déclaration ou de
procéder par sondages
parce que la tâche le conseil
constitutionnel nous a beaucoup parlé
que le contrôle de 45 40 me de 4
millions de signatures était un sujet
mais las on n'en est pas là mais quand
même contrôlé de très près 8900
déclaration n'est pas une petite affaire
madame qu chairman
oui merci merci monsieur nadal pour
cette présentation effectivement
complète et précise qui montrent en tout
cas votre envie de vrai dans ce défi de
réconcilier vous l'avez dit finalement
l'ensemble des français avec leurs
représentants et de créer ce se gardent
de confiance moi j'avais une remarque
qui va rejoindre un petit peu ce qui
vient d'être révoqué par monsieur y est
sûre le rapport finalement entre les
élus et les différents conflits
d'intérêts puisque nous avions dans le
cadre du débat parlementaire déposé
plusieurs amendements sur
la question des lobbys qui aujourd'hui
pèse aussi en tout cas a même beaucoup
de suspicion pour quelques-uns amène
aussi des dérives nous avons eu nous
voyons parfois
donc même si ce n'est pas
précisément dans le texte de loi à ce
jour cela va forcément donner à mener
votre commission a travaillé j'ai envie
de dire de vous poser comme question
aurez vous les moyens les possibilités
et si oui de quelle façon de traiter
également cette question là même si au
vu du nombre du dos de dossiers que vous
nous évoquer je ne doute pas que votre
vos journées seront déjà bien bien
remplie et chargé mais nous croyons en
tout cas que cette question qui pèse
aussi fortement et qui est aussi une
question de la confiance à rétablir
entre le rapport des lobbys des élus
comment est ce que l'élu s'appuie sur
effectivement les personnes qui n'en
sont pas qu'ils peuvent avoir des
responsabilités qui peuvent avoir des
compétences sans être soumis à la
pression de certains grands groupes je
remercie madame culte sherman madame
tasca
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
procureur général parmi les grands
principes du droit que vous avez
évoquées comme devant être
équilibré vous avez cité la séparation
des pouvoirs
il y a beaucoup d'autorités
indépendantes dans nos institutions
désormais mais celle ci a la
particularité
d'avoir pour assujettis des élus
comment pensez vous que
la haute autorité
pourra tracer sa savoie entre la mission
de contrôle qui est la sienne et le
respect de la séparation des pouvoirs
merci madame d'ascq à mes chers
collègues y at il d'autres demandes
d'intervention n'hésitez pas
chacun peut s'exprimer
oui monsieur jean bien michel vous le
savez trop bien mais vous savez que
c'est très important de pouvoir
s'exprimer bien alors puisque tout le
monde eux se reconnaît dans les
questions qui ont été posées qu'il n'y a
pas de questions complémentaires donc
monsieur le procureur général
vous disposez d'une vingtaine de minutes
pour répondre aux orateurs un de manière
à ce que l'on soit fidèle au rendez-vous
du vote merci dans la parole
merci monsieur le président je vais tout
de suite si vous voulez et je suis ici
je suis extrêmement sensible
croyez le quand vous adressez à moi en
mesurant le procureur général je veux
dire tout de suite immédiatement je ne
suis pas destiné à exercer ma fonction
comme si c'était un sixième poste de
procureur non alors là je vous rassure
tout de suite tout de suite c'est
essentiel
l'expérience même de passé moi
l'expression de la pâte humaine
confrontés aux dysfonctionnements
individuels et collectifs que j'ai vu
dans le moule de l'institution
judiciaire comme procureur mais qui me
permet de tirer aussi ce qu'il ya de
plus utile dans une démocratie c'est à
dire le conseil le dialogue la confiance
c'est cela qui va ma et ça ne sera
plus les débats que j'ai connu deux
l'inquisitoire du voyeurisme
de l'accusatoire on sera ciblée sur un
système de fonctionnement clair de
confiance de contradictoire si je devais
sortir un maillon des procédures
que j'ai cherché pendant 40 années c'est
le mot contradictoires celle équilibre
et je vous en donne même une
démonstration la plus chaude la plus
dernière puisque comme vous l'avez
rappelé je viens de déposer un dernier
regard des sceaux un rapport sur la
refondation du ministère public et je
suis à l'initiative qui montrent que je
suis un garant des libertés
individuelles fondamentales de à savoir
que la défense les avocats de vrais et
doivent avoir accès au dossier au cours
des enquêtes préliminaires qui durent
trop longtemps et comme également
l'avocat doit être présent au moment du
différement ce qui ne se fait pas pour
que le dialogue s'instaure entre et que
ce soit pas des isberguois sochaux et
d'isis père du nil et d'une légalité
froide qui qui brille tellement sévices
et rentrent violente le rapport le
rapport humain
sachez cela c'était essentiel c'est
c'est mon esprit c'est faire en sorte
que la haute autorité soit devienne le
temple de la déontologie de la vie
républicaine et que je puisse si vous
voulez par les relations que la
dynamique que je mettrai en oeuvre
rassembler tout ce qui a au fil du temps
par ce vent de transparence qui souffle
depuis déjà pas mal d'années mais dans
tous les sens la transparence ça ne veut
pas dire aussi passer mon expression le
voyeurisme tout n'importe quoi il ya des
limites c'est le respect comme il y
avait la présomption d'innocence en
passer et bien il y aura avec moi de ma
présomption d'un bonne foi il y croyait
j'ai au moins le mérite de vous dire une
chose il peut y avoir des fois tu sens
fautif faute terre faut être lucide il
faut traiter tout au moins comme je
saisis de la force et vous y avait
contribué et je vous envoie aux mages
car j'ai beaucoup apprécié que la
lecture de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel tient incontestablement
même si elle n'a pas suivi en tous
points appel quand même à une grande
mesure entre le secteur de l'intérêt
général qui est essentiel et le respect
fondamental du la vie privée et madame
le ministre j'ajoute tout de suite de la
séparation des pouvoirs
je la haute autorité que j'ai faire
présider n'est pas un contre pouvoir
le parlement sera le sénat l'assemblée
seront respectés dans leurs attributions
intrinsèque et j'espère je vous parle
avec mon coeur comme je vois les choses
en devenir j'espère que on n'arrivera
pas que vous n'arriverez pas dans le
bureau du sénat à cette hypothèse
d'aller en dernier recours devant le
conseil constitutionnel
dans tout ce travail qui va être un
travail de dialogue l'outil n'est pas un
outil répressif c'est pas ainsi que je
ne concevrais c'est un outil de dialogue
un outil de conseil elle est un outil de
des changes qui doit être fondamental de
confiance car ça me paraît une donnée
essentielle de la réussite de la haute
autorité créée la confiance est le
garant la confiance faire en sorte que
cette suspicion qui tease qui s'abat sur
le monde politique
apparaissent comme vraiment sans
fondement et pour arriver ainsi si ça
abattage c et d contribuer à avoir une
pédagogie je suis prêt je vous le dis
librement vous me connaissez pour la
plupart de venir à certaines échéances
qu'on peut même dans un espèce de timing
mettre au point des que
l'autorité se mettra en marche venir
devant vous vous dire les difficultés
que je pourrais rencontrer comment
j'envisage avec ce qui est important et
qui me meut consolide dans l'espoir que
je porte dans cette institution avec la
collégialité j'aime certains ici le
savent très bien travaillé avec des
cultures différentes avec des gens
différents et il est évident
que personne détient la vérité pas plus
moi même que tout autre mais le
croisement des compétences et des
regards peuvent permettre d'avancer vers
la vérité et de mettre en place
socle sur lequel la démocratie par soir
sa probité son intégrité sa
respectabilité je m'y emploierai je m'y
emploierai beaucoup ses nombreux d'entre
vous me connaissent je mettrai tout
toute mon énergie avec la collégialité
avec les experts j'ai même pensé je vous
dis même chose à travers tout ce qui
pouvait vous préoccupez sur les
déclarations de patrimoine août intérêts
et cetera il va se poser un problème qui
n'a pas été appréhendé pour - évaluer
comment être dans un périmètre de
crédibilité et de fiabilité
j'ai pensé j'y ai pensé je pense que les
moyens qu en tout cas cela je je je les
revendique ray je pourrais avoir un
comité d'experts il y aura des experts
comptables et commissaires aux comptes
et spécialiste qui fait que dans le
dialogue avec l'intéressé ou avec une
collectivité tout sera clair et
transparent chaque fois que je mettrai
dans l'élaboration du dispositif un
outil qui peut rendre encore plus
transparents et dépouillant toute
suspicion sur la sur les sur les
assujettis pour tous d'ailleurs ce soit
le gouvernement le parle l'assemblée
nationale le sénat la haute fonction
publique etc les différentes personnes
qui vont avoir à s'avancer vers cette
maison et bien je veux leur dire une
chose et ils peuvent et pourront avancer
sans crainte parce que personne ne
détient la vérité pas plus l'élu qui
portera sa déclaration d'intérêts ou sa
déclaration de patrimoine il peut y
avoir une zone qui mais qui n'est pas
gliese un trouble dans ce trou je suis
là pour le dissiper et dans la
confidentialité c'est c c'est une
dimension de la république qui me paraît
de relever d'une exigence sans précédent
c'est cela la déontologie
c'est un jeu je demanderai à chacun et à
chaque secteur qui pourrait être
confronté 2
exercer deux par lui-même naturellement
ce surcroît de déontologie dont la
république a besoin de par ses acteurs
exigences à l'égard de soi même exigence
à l'égard d'autrui exigences à l'égard
de la société quel que soit sont les
étiquettes politiques
c'est je vois sûr je serai impartiale
neutre et j'examinerai gevrey mon
travail en toute conscience pour le bien
public pour la république alors
je vais essayer de lever quelques
quelques de dissiper quelques quelques
préoccupations c'est vrai attendez c'est
une maison que je vais lancer j'espère
lancé si vous me conduisait mais je le
ferai avec détermination et avec tact
parce que tant la loi dans les textes il
ya des zones qui vont mériter d'être
tout de suite tout de suite passé moi
l'expression verrouillé pour sécuriser
les déclarations c'est vrai qu'ils vont
préfecture
tente ailleurs on sait pas sous quelle
forme ça sera sur papier
informatique avec
éventuellement des observations pour
voir si c'est sincère exhaustif exact
autant de au temps passé moi
l'expression de deux concepts dont la
dont la la fragilité peut mettre en
appétit il faut le dire des gens
malveillants je veillerai et sur les les
veilleurs dallaire sur le notamment sur
les
côtés que les lanceurs d'alert je serai
prudent et je souhaite que la haute
autorité soit garante des libertés
individuelles c'est à dire de la vie
privée et le traitement des
dénonciations calomnieuses l'art je
retrouverai mon arme d'anciens magistrat
ira vers l'autorité judiciaire il n'y
aura à cet égard aucun cadeau à faire à
ceux qui voudraient troubler le jeu
d'inconscience de des élus qui le font
en toute bonne foi et j'ai dans la
discussion
je serai je puis vous dire même si c'est
vrai ça pose mais je le ferai me pas
d'un effort et je ne frémit pas voir la
méthode il va falloir que très
rapidement
j'ajuste comment va fonctionner la haute
autorité car j'ai fait pendant tout le
camp drian tête mais il ya plusieurs
vagues il y en a une qui va arriver le
1er février
bienvenue dans juin et une en octobre je
m'emploierai et soyez assurés à ce que
tout se passe bien je viendrais même
préalablement peut être devant votre
bureau vous parler sur ce que je mets en
place pour pas que en achat on appelle
les choses le cycle ça non je serai très
clair alors sur ses déclarations c'est
vrai en préfecture il faudra être très
prudent
j'y veillerai
ça me paraît le président sur
une alerte fondé
je l'assumerai avec une équipe un
collège deux cas même composé de deux
conseillères cour de cassation deux
conseillers d'état de conseiller maître
à la cour des comptes des personnalités
qualifiées un des rapporteurs un
secrétaire général et je crée un cercle
d'experts parce qu'on a besoin
maintenant le partenariat que je vais
mettre en mouvement un partenariat en
interne de compétences diversifiées et
ajustés aux objectifs recherchés par
pour apaiser le fonctionnement de cette
institution et ne pas causer dans la
république de troubles j'ose espérer
c'est une ambition et mon regard vers va
vers la madame le ministre
j'irai puiser si vous le permettez et
vous rencontrez dans le gisement de
déontologie que vous avez mis en place
ici avec le bureau nous serons en
contact étroit non seulement dans la
conception mais dans le modus operandi
je viendrai vous consultez je viendrai
vous dire et je suis prêt à venir même
avant la publication du rapport qui sera
quand même la première pierre importante
qui sera en fin d'année un an après je
viendrai plus oh que je vous envoyait
ses rapports que souvent personne ne lit
ou nouveau à la table des matières ou
encore la synthèse je viendrai vous en
parler avant longuement une matinée où
on échangera réciproquement j'allais
dire synallagmatique mans comme un
contrat de confiance vous me direz ce
que vous paraît devoir être améliorés
ira le zain et le solène si cela la
navette républicaine du progrès je vais
m'y employer vous pouvez en être assuré
monsieur le président y est qu'ils nous
écoutent toujours et toujours écouté et
ailleurs avec avec un intérêt et je le
dis avec respect
et amitié
j'ose le dire devant tout le monde ici
la bt dans les rapports avec la justice
un modèle et un interlocuteur permanent
qui a toujours eu la juste mesure de ce
qu'il convenait de faire ou de ne pas
faire
alors c'est évident que la question que
vous posez et elle va se prouver elle va
se poser elle va se poser vous l'avez vu
plus tôt massivement peut-être du côté
des élus locaux dans tout ce qui touche
les marchés les commandes et là il faut
reconnaître les choses soyons clairs
transparents
comme vous l'avez souvent dit dans vos
dans vos rapports
la sédimentation
des institutions a rempli une telle
opacité qu' il y as est vrai une vertu
des chèques
avant de me lancer
dans ce secteur je me suis renseigné
pour savoir combien de
combien de darty 40 à l'autorité
judiciaire
combien de ceux ci comme bien de la
la mission interministérielle des
marchés publics on a vu ce que ça
donnait
traque fin isolé même s'ils forment un
bon travail le service de lutte de
preuves de protection de de prévention
de la corruption
là c'est très transparent
je n'ai rien vu
mais alors vraiment rien et ça siège au
ministère de la justice c'est inquiétant
aucun lien
vraiment bull à tout cela s'interpellent
et finalement je pense que vos lois
elles sont elles vont même la france et
j'y compte au premier rang dans ce
domaine là et je vous dis une chose
vous m'avez posé la question des
associations de lutte contre la
corruption
je veillerai
oui je veillerai à ce que les critères
soient des critères sérieux et j'aurai
dans mon équipe un juriste
qui publiera une étude que je vous
transmettrai
permanence sérieux de des associations
qui pourront s'adresser à moi et je vous
le dit d'ailleurs j'ai une énorme
considération pour transparancy
international qui est dû surtout à à
l'aura de son président daniel lebègue
qui a été un grand commis de l'état au
trésor qui a été oh je crois au cabinet
de pierre mauroy et qui a une grande
carrière dans la banque en terminant en
tête la caisse des dépôts et
consignations
mais je pense que de cette subjectivité
de sondage qui nous met au 22e rang
j'espère et je m'y emploierai de faire
en sorte que par là l'objective isation
la doctrine le droit la jurisprudence on
arrive à des subjectivités et a quitté
cette 22e place pour monter haut du
podium je m'y emploierai
moyens
le président sûr on va parler des moyens
alors oui évidemment des moyens il va
falloir et je voudrais serait à vous si
j'ai estiment insuffisant
c'est une tâche colossale
c'est une tâche colossale je crois
savoir que ça démarrera dans les anciens
locaux de la commission qui a un bail
qui est prévue
qui est en cours les fonctionnaires je
crois qu'il va y en avoir une vingtaine
le créer de ce que je crois savoir des
crédits fonctionnement a priori me
paraît insuffisant mais ça je me dirais
une fois dans la maison
on me connaît je suis un bâtisseur je ne
prends pas de responsabilité à la légère
et j'entends que les moyens soient
accompagnés alors c'est vrai j'éviterai
monsieur le président sur les vitres et
les les sondages la main heureuse ou
malheureuse non cheschire est d'avoir
une doctrine c'est avec la collégialité
ça va être un travail de titan mais on y
arrivera
je n'ai jamais eu peur des tâches
importantes et j'ai toujours fait preuve
de courage en république je pense que et
départ vous parce que il faudra m'aider
je voudrais me confier à vous c'est
important que se sentir soutenir soutenu
voilà pour les moyens madame munitions
crois que josé répondu
ah oui alors là sur les problèmes c'est
un problème effectivement il faudra
qu'on y voie clair sur ces problèmes des
lobbys sur ces problèmes des groupes des
groupes d' influence de tout ce qui se
passe derrière le la scène de la
république
chaque chose en son temps on en parlera
jeu mais c'est un travail d équipe
j'attends avec l'équipe que j'aurais qui
sera j'en suis convaincu j'espère que la
cour de cassation le conseil d'état est
là et la cour des comptes
nous donnerons
t2 au magistrat très spécialisées très
compétent j'en suis confiant et toujours
travailler j'ai été un
celui qui a initié le dialogue des juges
dans ce pays
quand je suis arrivée à la cour de
cassation croyez moi la théorie de
l'apparence a été volé en éclats sait
plus qui faisait quoi et puis dialoguer
avec toutes ses institutions y compris
cour européenne
est-ce que vous pensez que j'ai encore
peut-être essayer malgré moi
des zones d'ombré
vous n'avez pas pu tout dire monsieur le
vrai monsieur le procureur général je ne
me trompe pas vous n'avez pas pu tout
dire mais vous avez répondu avec chaleur
avec vigueur et détermination je pense
que chacun aura pu le remarquer ici dont
il me reste à vous remercier pour vos
propos pour avoir fait preuve de cette
conviction de ses convictions devant
nous tout en respectant strictement le
temps imparti
donc je vous remercie et je donne
rendez-vous précisément à mes collègues
puisque je rappelle pour tout le monde
que le dépouillement doit avoir lieu à
la même heure exactement à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat
donc je vous donne rendez vous dans la
salle de la commission 216 où le vote
aura lieu à 12h30 précises donc dans 5
minutes et je vous remercie encore tous
et toutes et merci monsieur le procureur
général
merci monsieur le président merci à vous
tous
voilà vous avez pu suivre l'audition de
jean-louis nadal devant la commission
des lois du sénat jean vandal a été
nommé hier président de la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique tout de suite on retrouve une
delphine girard pour 24 heures sénat
alors quand